[Music]
the sun
rises behind her eyes
but she still can't see it
and she's beside me i walk
slowly
[Music]
she feeds my soul all the gold i could
need
welcome back to my channel so i am in
wyoming at the moment
um i've been staying in the grand tetons
for
i guess it's been three weeks now and oh
my gosh i love it
today i want to talk about one of my
biggest questions that i get
how do i make money so a lot of you
you know you see this lifestyle and
you're like okay cool you live in a van
and it seems like you never work you're
always in beautiful places
like how do you do that is someone
paying your way like how do you make
money on the road
in this video i'm going to share how i
personally earn a remote income
while living on the road full-time and
how i diversify my revenue streams
and also a little bit of background
about what led me to here
i was born in jonesboro arkansas and my
mom had new when she was really young
she was 16 so we lived with my
grandparents until i was six
and then uh she wanted to break out
on her own so we lived in a car for a
little while
ended up in wisconsin where we lived in
a basement
and she sold books door to door i did
not
grow up with money we were on food
stamps for the whole time as far as i
can remember
and yeah so i'll just put it that way
however my parents
did always encourage me to focus on my
education
and um to have a hard work ethic
i got a job working at a burger joint
called culver's
in oshkosh wisconsin at pick n save and
the produce department
from there i started working at a shoe
store
famous footwear i also worked as a pool
waitress at the country club that's a
little bit of background that led me up
to college
i went to college for my first year at
the university of wisconsin
oshkosh and then i decided i was just
over wisconsin
and i wanted to try something new so
since i was paying for myself i decided
why not pay to go to hawaii
so i sold everything that i had and i
had four cardboard boxes
that i shipped out to hawaii i did not
know a single person i was actually
supposed to move out there with
a good friend and then at the last
minute her parents were like
we'll get you an apartment and a car if
you'll stay so she stayed
sad very sad but it all worked out
anyway i ended up going to school in
hawaii the university of hawaii manoa
and i studied uh business so i got my
bachelor of business administration and
i also got
a minor in spanish and
oh my gosh probably the best decision
i've ever made in my whole life
was going to school in hawaii
it was very expensive i remember
specifically a gallon of milk was seven
dollars i ended up
working a ton of different jobs first i
started working at
abercrombie fitch as a model while going
to school full-time
and then i also picked up a job as a
waitress i ended up working at
i think like four or five different
restaurants then i also started modeling
and that paid the bulk of my bills um i
did like
magazines runway uh i was an extra
lost i hosted events for like rolex
and um oh i did one for tiffany's oh no
sorry harry winston
that was really fun they like put me in
this big gown and i had to wear
diamonds and walk around and people
would buy them and
weird stuff yeah and also craigslist
gigs i got you know like some hosting
jobs
i worked as a retail manager at puma and
also starbucks and ended up back at
abercrombie which i loved i ended up
working with them for eight years
in hawaii managing two different stores
and then i went to california
colorado ohio and kentucky and then
i asked my manager if there was any way
i could move up to the international
team so i interviewed for that
and that's when things really changed i
went over to
london and i managed um the flagship
store there and then i was sent to italy
meanwhile i was taking italian lessons
so i also speak fluent italian when i
showed up
at the store in italy i just it was a
completely different dialect than what i
had learned company italian is very like
um
it's very different being fully immersed
in a different country
not only having to like function as an
adult and
a member of society there like learning
how to say how do i turn on my heat
to communicate job duties and build
relationships
i had a great time there i learned a lot
one of those things being that the
corporate life was not for me when that
contract ended
i just took time off i shipped all my
stuff from my southern
italian apartment to a storage unit in
the us and
i just took a backpack and started
traveling and that turned into 11 months
of traveling i ended up going around the
world like that wasn't intentional
just kept going from country to country
started dating someone in the middle
east
and we moved together to monterey
california
um i again didn't know anyone there but
he had a job offer there so
he was like do you want to move in
together so i started looking around at
different retail positions
and i just realized that my heart wasn't
in it like i'd do anything to
not have to go back to that nine to five
lifestyle
so what i ended up doing is what i had
done in college i just went on
craigslist and started looking at gig
listings
and there was this local artist slash
painter
photographer that was looking for an
assistant to work just six hours a week
i did everything from like
clearing out her garage to applying for
her
dual citizenship in a different country
to
sending out email newsletters helping
with social media
uh contacting pr people she generously
introduced me to her friends
and over time i built a clientele list
of 12
different like artists videographers
painters sculptors
small business owners and that was
amazing i was loving it but at the same
time i was really falling in love with
big sur and taking photos and exploring
the area and i was
really really wanting to build my
photography portfolio so i
at the time was planning a trip to do
the john muir trail that is a 240 mile
trek
through the sierra nevada wilderness
leading up to that trip i was
posting on instagram and kind of getting
my work out there
a pr agent who represented samsung
reached out and said hey do you have any
cool trips coming up
um we'd love to collaborate with you in
some way and i was like well i actually
have the jmt
that's kind of where my um
exploration into a career as a
photographer began
i realized that it was actually pretty
lucrative especially when you
tie social media into it so for the past
five years i've been building my career
as a freelance photographer and a
content creator
so what does that look like like what
does that even mean i partner with
brands and tourism boards to
create engaging content um through video
storytelling photography and they use
that content either on their website or
social media channels maybe there's a
new product launch and they want to
create a lot of energy around that so i
collaborate with them
to promote that product or new launch um
for tourism boards i'm going traveling
to that location
usually on a travel itinerary to
experience some of the best
excursions and just beautiful
destinations that that place has to
offer and i'm sharing that through a
blog post or
through my own social media channels and
then again they're using
my photos to promote like on
billboard advertising magazine
advertising etc
i work with a lot of tech brands luxury
brands
and outdoor gear outdoor adventure type
brands
some examples of clients that i have
worked with are land rover cannon
adobe acura phase one nike
mazda eddie bauer visit reno tahoe visit
florida
visit dominican republic samsung travel
alberta
what that looks like in working with
brands is typically we'll sign a
contract where they're giving me
x amount of dollars for x amount of
deliverables
some examples of deliverables are image
assets photos that they can use for
social web or
white listing additional paid
advertising um
image licensing or also i would create
content and then share it on my social
media channels be that instagram
or youtube and also blog posts linking
back
to that brand's website there's quite a
few different ways that you can work
with brands but those are just some
general examples in terms of revenue
streams i have six different sources of
income
and i'm going to go over each of those
but first i want to
spin off of what i just talked about
sponsored
content so this video
is sponsored by logitech it's actually
my first youtube sponsorship
ever so pretty stoked on that this guy
right here is that in focus
this is the logitech mx anywhere
3. what i do requires sitting in front
of a computer for
a long period of time having a mouse
just i don't know it makes big
difference
this mouse is a whole new level it
literally works on any kind of surface
i can use it on my dust surface i can
use it on my
bed which is crazy i'm looking at this
beautiful view
and i can just work on my laptop i can
use it at a picnic table
stays powered for up to 70 days on a
full charge
and it is usb powered it also has button
customization for photoshop and premiere
pro it's also just good to
not have that repetitive motion like
sometimes i will sit on my laptop and
not use the mouse
but then it's really good to have other
times when i can use the mouse and just
to switch it up and kind of give my
hands a break
it's a simple clean design which i love
and
it's built to withstand road life i am
not going to lie
i dropped it once already still works
like a champ it's
79.99 comes in three different colors
i obviously chose this clean white and
gray color because it matches the fan
and i love that if you want to check it
out there is a link
below thank you again logitech for
sponsoring this video
so that is revenue stream number one for
me sponsored content
primarily on instagram now youtube for
the first time ever
i just want to point out how important
it is that
if you're gonna go down this road you
work with brands
that you actually use you actually trust
you actually
would buy anyway second is commercial
photography
and image licensing when a brand is
having a product launch
they will typically bring uh someone
like me on board
and i'm doing multiple jobs taking
photos sharing instagram stories
sharing content on my personal social
media channels
maybe i'm doing a blog post but
primarily i'm there to do
heights and angles povs all kinds of
different
uh image assets of that product that
they can then use for media releases
their website
uh advertising and whatnot so that makes
up
kind of like the combination of those
two things is what makes up the bulk of
my
income number three modeling so when i
was in college i did this on a more
regular basis
more recently like in the past couple of
years i've worked with nike to launch
one of their um
i think it was the fall collection i
modeled for black diamond
for a new product launch that was
centered around their new line of rain
gear
and so for eddie bauer we were sent to
peru and we had a uh
additional photographer and videographer
there and we were basically just out
hiking and exploring cusco and the
surrounding areas and we're being
documented while doing that that they
can then use for their in-store
marketing
and uh yeah just promoting the new fall
collection
number four print sales so i
am a landscape photographer
i have a print shop i do work with a
company now that makes it possible to
still
sell prints while on the road and that's
a pretty good source of income
especially around christmas season so
yeah if you're interested in seeing my
work and you want to maybe buy a print
head over to my print shop
number five youtube ad revenue i
had no idea that you could make money on
youtube in this way
um and unfortunately i missed out on the
bulk of it because i didn't sign up for
monetization until like after my van
tour video had really picked up
but that's okay like the amount of money
that i
do make from ad revenue it's it's enough
to encourage me to keep coming on here
and
and posting content that you guys find
valuable so
thank you to all of you who are watching
and
number six affiliate links um
i really don't pour a lot of energy into
this i just recently started putting
links down in my youtube
captions but i don't promote these
anywhere else except for my website
i have like one little button that says
gear that i use it's like a
very very small kickback but hey it's
cool i
honestly i think i've made like 200
since
beginning affiliate link so it's not
even it wouldn't even make it on the pie
chart if i were to
do a pie chart of my income sources but
i'm hoping that will grow over time
because it's a passive source of income
and passive is always the goal okay so
how much can you actually make while
living on the road
um that entirely depends on how hard you
hustle and how talented you are
and the connections you have a lot of
things play into that i make a decent
income i make more than i made as a
you know living the corporate life as an
international general manager working
overseas
so i think like i said if you're willing
to work hard
and you're willing to do the research
and yeah really invest in your craft
whatever that may be
you can definitely make a good living
even living in a van
on the road working remotely a lot of
companies are reevaluating
whether or not they actually need their
employees to come in
and sit at a desk and pay for office
space if you can
convince your employer um to maybe let
you start working remotely one day today
maybe more often and you can build that
trust maybe you also could work remotely
and live on the road and wake up to
beautiful vistas and then go find
someplace with wi-fi
and sit down and work because that's
what that's what my life looks like
at least 50 of the time i want to show
you guys
this view
this is why i love to live on the road
you guys like
i'm working and and i'm technically in
my office but
i can just take a break and step outside
and
it's so nice but i just want to say
thank you to everyone who
is still watching my channel and um i'm
excited to put up more content for you
guys
so yeah let me know in the comments
below what you think
if you have any other questions and
if you want to see examples of
commercial work that i do check out my
website
i'll link that below and um i'm not sure
what i'm going to make
the next video about but if you guys
have suggestions
let me know talk to you soon